[Music]
on this thursday night more help for
canadians during the covid crisis
ottawa extends the serve and modifies ei
i think millions of workers are going to
be very relieved plus who's eligible for
three new benefit programs
warnings about the we charity deal the
liberal minister who thought it was a
bad idea
from fighting russia's government to
fighting for his life
the vocal critic of the kremlin now in a
coma
and risking their lives in the quest for
better ones
i have no choice the perilous journey
for migrants
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
there's financial relief tonight for
canadians who've taken a major hit to
their earnings over the past few months
the federal government is rolling out a
sweeping 37 billion dollar
income support plan for workers affected
by the pandemic
among the new measures the canada
emergency response benefit
widely known as the serb is being
extended there's a revamped employment
insurance system
and three new benefit programs instead
of giving every canadian
a little bit of money when every
canadian doesn't necessarily need it we
are focused with these benefits on
canadian workers in particular
and are able to give them more because
of that choice
but all of this has to get through the
house of commons first
and with parliament pro-rogued that
means a confidence vote
in september our chief political
correspondent david aiken has been
digging
into the details david well you know
robin the serb has been the workhorse of
ottawa's coven 19 support plants more
than
eight million canadians have received at
least one serb check this year and
four million are still counting on the
serb benefit but the end of serb is in
sight
to be replaced by a revamped employment
insurance program
the new ei system will allow recipients
to qualify
with just 120 hours of work that's
really only three and a half
weeks anytime in the last year it also
includes a minimum benefit
of four hundred dollars a week but to
get it you'll have to be available for
work and looking for work
just like under the old ei system but
not everyone qualifies for ei and for
those
three new benefit programs first the
canada recovery benefit
that's aimed at the self-employed it
will provide 400
a week for up to 26 weeks and the
self-employed
can continue to earn up to 38 000
a year and still get that benefit for
those who earn more than that
the government will start to claw back
the benefit but do it at tax time
the government also wants to make sure
that no one goes to work feeling sick
so it will bring in a canada recovery
sickness benefit
this will allow canadians not covered by
an employee or
other sick lead program to receive five
hundred dollars a week
for two one-week periods over the next
year
if they feel ill finally there is the
canada recovery caregiving benefit
for parents who cannot work because they
have to care for young children
if schools or day care centers remain
closed
that benefit will pay 500 dollars per
week per household
for 26 weeks starting september 27th
but if your child's school or daycare
opens
you cannot claim this benefit now
there's a lot of fine print to these
plans and applications will open online
for these programs in september but all
these new benefits require
legislation that has to be approved by
the house of commons but of course prime
minister justin trudeau just
prorogued or suspended parliament so the
house will not get a chance to even look
at the legislation until late september
and since it's a minority government
these benefits will depend on the
liberals
winning a confidence vote in what will
be a high-stakes game of political poker
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
for many canadians these new benefits
will help solve old problems that date
back to before the pandemic
with economic recovery front of mind in
ottawa
advocates are calling for the changes to
be permanent
it's sad that it's taken a pandemic and
this many people
affected to get government to move and
do the right thing
but there appears to be a recognition
that the time
it's is well past making these changes
those three new benefit programs
announced by the federal government
today are expected to cost
22 billion dollars turning now to the we
charity controversy and what we're
learning after a major government
document dump
thousands of pages of records related to
the we deal were released this week
and there is a consistent theme of one
government department
pushing back it turns out the treasury
board in charge of holding canada's
purse strings
had serious concerns and global news can
confirm the liberal minister who heads
the agency
raised red flags abigail beeman reports
among the thousands of pages of released
documents the hundreds from the treasury
board seem to be the most redacted
but what is clear from what's left on
the page officials raised a number of
concerns about the we
charity deal among other things some of
those salaries look a little steep
flag to staffer looks like 900 million
in grants
20 million admin wrote another that is
an awful lot of money
responded the first on may 4th the
treasury board secretariat notes
employment and social development canada
has not provided evidence to suggest
that we charities possess the capacity
to undertake this work
especially under accelerated timelines
furthermore the tracking of hours by a
third
party could be challenging and result in
potential integrity concerns
then may 8 the day the prime minister
says he pulled the student grant program
from the agenda in a call for more due
diligence
a staffer flagged this slide from we
margaret trudeau and sophie gregoire
trudeau
are featured as some of we celebrity
ambassadors the email simply reads
came across this today while preparing
for min dim
that's a meeting between the minister
and deputy minister
and the concerns about handing the 900
million dollar deal to we went right up
to the minister
liberal jeannie duclos spoke out about
red flags
is the reliance on a third party we
charities going to lead to an over
centralized structure i also queried
about the administrative costs
we and we charities are not particularly
well known in quebec
looking at their website i also see not
a single word
or page in french the treasury board
tells us the questions they posed are
part of their regular
quote challenge role as the student
grant proposal evolved they said
so did their advice but on may 22nd the
treasury board was still flagging
concerns
including about the program's integrity
and may 22nd is the day
the deal was approved by cabinet abigail
beeman global news
ottawa it's an anxious time for
thousands of people in british columbia
there are more than 90 fires burning in
the province today is expected to be a
critical day in the wildfire fight
all eyes are on the weather there's a
chance of rain in the penticton region
the site of the largest fire in bc but
friday's forecast also calls for high
winds
and the possibility of a thunderstorm
which could fuel the flames
erin mcarthur is on the ground in the
okanagan again for us tonight
erin robin the concern
is growing here in the okanagan valley
the fire
is bigger and now the wind is starting
to pick up
the christie mountain wildfire still
looming in the hills above penticton
overnight growing to 20 square
kilometers
since we're moving into the hottest
driest part of the day here sort of in
that mid afternoon
we do expect to see fire activity pick
up
more than 80 people are on the ground
and helicopters are constantly dropping
water on the hot spots
trying to force the fire back in on
itself
the primary goal for firefighters on the
ground protecting people's property
we just need to ask our citizens to be
patient
we're going to do everything we can to
assist bc wildfire to get this under
control
and eventually get them back into their
homes
the evacuation order remains in place
for 319 homes
and about 3 700 more are on evacuation
alert
people have been told to pack and be
ready to leave at a moment's notice
among those getting ready penticton's
mayor i can understand how all the
people feel
if anything does happen and you lose all
your heirlooms and
your your family history we have to be
very very careful as to what happens
the forecast over the next 24 hours is a
real problem for people fighting this
fire
there is lightning predicted as well as
strong winds with gusts
maybe as high as 70 kilometers an hour
that could potentially put thousands
more people
directly in the path of the fire if it
makes a run
robin aaron macarthur nbc thanks erin
in california a pilot fighting fires has
died after his chopper crashed
the state has more than 360 wildfires
this is what it looked like in vacaville
west of sacramento
an inferno tore through that city
overnight it's believed most of the
fires were caused by a heat wave
combined with
unprecedented lightning that produced
nearly 11 000 strikes
in the past 72 hours donald trump's
former advisor has been arrested and is
facing several charges steve bannon and
three others are accused of a fraud
scheme to raise money to
help build a wall along the southern u.s
border the online campaign raised more
than 25 million dollars
prosecutors allege bannon received more
than a million dollars
trump says he had no involvement in the
project
i didn't like that project i thought
that was a project that was being done
for
showboating reasons i don't know that he
was in charge i didn't know any of the
other people either
but it's it's sad it's very sad
bannon is not the first person
associated with trump's 2016
campaign to be charged five other men
paul manafort rick gates michael flynn
roger stone
and michael cohen have all faced federal
charges
the u.s president has suffered another
major legal setback in his fight to stop
the release of his tax returns
this is just a continuation of the
most hideous witch hunt in the history
of our country
the president has been locked in a
lengthy battle with manhattan's top
prosecutor
who wants trump's records as part of an
investigation into his business
practices
trump's lawyers have filed an appeal
it's the final night of the democratic
national convention and joe biden will
deliver his acceptance speech
as the party's presidential candidate
jackson prosko joins us from wilmington
delaware jackson what message can we
expect from biden and what will his tone
be
well robin tonight is the night where
joe biden will really really lay out his
vision his sense of what his presidency
will look like we expect him to spend
time
focusing on specifics of things like how
he would deal with the pandemic the
economic collapse
and the ongoing reckoning in this
country over systemic racism
we do not expect him to spend much time
talking about president donald trump or
really going on the attack
why would he when guests over the last
three nights have done that for him last
night
former president barack obama laid in to
president trump really spoke about the
threats to american democracy
so did kamala harris in her historic
acceptance speech
as she solidified her position as the
vice presidential nominee
really what we're expecting from biden
is him to lay out a vision of what
people could be voting for
as opposed to simply voting for him as
someone who's not donald trump
robin speaking of donald trump he's been
trying to provide a counter campaign to
this convention and today he was in joe
biden's hometown in pennsylvania
is his strategy working
you know democrats feel like they've
really captured the country's attention
during this convention despite it being
a virtual format they've been very happy
with the ratings for both tv
and online but you're right the
president has been crisscrossing the
country all week long
popping up in key battleground states
trying to steal some of the attention
and you're right
he was just down the road from here in
biden's hometown of scranton
pennsylvania
tonight there are some pro-trump
protesters outside this venue
but we should point out that there is
still a level of disarray within the
republican party it's less than a week
until their convention starts
yet we still don't know who's speaking
on what night there's still no scheduled
event or program for that event
that is creeping up very quickly robin
all we know about the republican party
convention is that it's likely to
feature donald trump in a prominent role
every single night next week jackson
proskow in delaware thanks jackson
there's a new development tonight in the
flint water crisis
the state of michigan has reached a
settlement to pay 600 million dollars to
compensate thousands of victims
in a community that was mostly black and
mostly poor
flint switched the source for its water
system in 2014 but the water was
improperly treated
allowing lead and other chemicals from
the pipes to leach in
authorities initially dismissed concerns
from residents they complained about
rashes hair loss
and other health concerns at least 12
people died
the city was eventually pushed to
improve water quality
following the international attention
suspicious circumstances surrounding
russia's
opposition leader coming up the
kremlin's fiercest critic
is in intensive care tonight
russian opposition leader alexei navalny
is in a coma
his doctor says he was poisoned just
before boarding a flight from siberia to
moscow
his allies blame the kremlin navalny is
among the most
fierce critics of russian president
vladimir putin but as redmond shannon
reports
it's just the latest apparent poisoning
of a putin opponent
and a warning some viewers may find the
video disturbing
this is alexi navalny drinking tea
before boarding a flight to moscow
two hours into the flight the plane
makes an emergency landing
navalny in agony in the toilet before
being taken to hospital
poisoning is being considered said a
hospital doctor
navalny's own doctor said it was
poisoning by an unknown agent
for more than a decade navalny has
campaigned against corruption
he refers to vladimir putin's united
russia as
the party of crooks and thieves he's
been jailed
and blocked from running for office and
suffered a possible poisoning in prison
last year throughout the putin era many
of his opponents or enemies have been or
claimed to have been poisoned dating
back to the killing of defector
alexander litvinenko
in 2006. russian canadian activist piotr
verzilov spent a month in hospital
after a suspected poisoning this has
been very similar to what i
have experienced in the first few hours
when similar thing happened to me
i have no doubt that that this was a
intentional
poisoning by the russian secret services
against lexi navalny i have no doubt
that putin ordered it
anti-corruption activist bill browder
thinks the timing may be connected to
the protests in neighboring belarus
these types of revolutions jump borders
and he's looking at who's the most
likely
person that would uh sort of step in to
rally
the people in russia and that's alexey
navalny the kremlin meanwhile is wishing
navalny
a speedy recovery redmond shannon global
news london
still ahead canada joins the
international community condemning the
military coup
in mali
the international community including
canada is condemning a coup
in mali soldiers forced the country's
democratically elected president to
resign on tuesday
the military leaders say they want
stability not power
and they're promising to set up a
civilian government and hold new
elections
but as eric sorensen explains they
haven't said when
that will happen the new self-declared
military leader of mali
colonel asimi goita tried to reassure
citizens that daily life and work can
now resume
a coup was necessary say the military
mutineers because the country was in
chaos
for months protesters had called for the
president of mali to resign
accused of corruption the country in
poverty this week
soldiers detained president ibrahim
quito reportedly at gunpoint
they surrounded his home in a televised
address cato said he was stepping down
adding do i really have a choice
the coup brought many people back to the
streets of the capitol only now in
celebration
it's liberation for the people of mali
says this man
but the reaction outside mali's borders
is deep concern
west african nations have called for a
return to civilian rule
the eu fears islamists will seize on the
instability
and from the united nations condemnation
the secretary general
calls for an immediate restoration of
constitutional order
and rule of law in mali ottawa has also
condemned the military junta
canada has sent millions in aid to mali
a peacekeeping mission that ended last
year ferried medical evacuations and
other assistance with canadian
helicopters
about 15 canadian forces members and
civilian police remain in mali
all are reported safe the canadian
embassy in bamako is offering help to
canadians if needed
but where does it leave the
international mission that was supposed
to support a government
not a military coup this is a huge
failure it's even embarrassing for an
international community for the u.n
the french the european union it's
certainly a very difficult
moment for the admission on the ground
one newspaper called the coup
black tuesday others are content with
the change but only for now
at some point says this man the military
should return government to civilians
and that's the question now that they've
seized power
will the military give it up and when
eric sorensen global news
toronto up next a migrant talks about
his dangerous journey across the english
channel
a tragic discovery on a french beach is
fueling calls in the uk
to do more to address the migrant crisis
the body of a young man from sudan was
found washed up
after he reportedly tried crossing the
english channel
thousands of asylum seekers have made
the same dangerous journey
crystal commansing spoke with one man
who took that risk
in hope of a new life these hands have
paid human smugglers climbed into
refrigerated trucks crossing borders
and in june clutched oars in an
inflatable raft rowing across the
english channel
yeah we me and my friend were partly
then about
11 12 hours then
then we lost then me and my friend
decide maybe we call
999 then maybe they can find us
nader ended up in jail and then a
detention center
we've agreed only to use his first name
and not show his face because he fears
telling his story
could damage his chances of being
allowed to stay in britain
he has made his way from afghanistan
through roughly a dozen countries he
says he has been beaten
robbed shot at even pushed back out to
sea
when he got close to grace every time
you know it's different
like some time is good you you
you face the good people sometimes
you're faced above people
for many desperate individuals at the
camp in france known as the cali jungle
the english channel and its
narrowest point of 32 kilometers
is worth the risk and more are
attempting it
the channel you know a pretty dangerous
stretch of water in
in potentially unseaworthy vessels we
want to stop that working with the
working with the french a year ago the
uk and france promised migrant crossings
in small boats would be an infrequent
phenomenon by spring 2020
roughly 4 thousand have crossed so far
this year
the united nations warned stopping these
migrants
could make people choose even more
dangerous routes
the rhetoric softened wednesday when the
body of a sixteen-year-old sudanese boy
washed up on a beach near cali
authorities say his
makeshift vessel capsized nader says
death
is always a risk i have no choice you
know
it was not easy but i had no choice he's
waiting to see if the government will
accept his asylum claim
crystal gamson global news london
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is white cliff park
in west vancouver bc
we'd love to see your corner of this
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you